[Music]
foreign
boxing the brand new Apple watch Ultra I
am so hyped to check this out because
ever since I saw it at the Apple event I
knew that this thing was going to be on
my wrist the second that I could get my
hands on one and today it is here and
we're about to unbox it here it is the
Apple watch Ultra this is the new Apple
watch Ultra with a 49 millimeter case
housing and always on Retina Display
capable of outputting 2000 nits which is
two times brighter than the series 8.
this means you'll have no problems
viewing in bright light conditions its
rugged design features a sapphire
display a 30 larger digital Crown an
aerospace grade titanium housing which
provides the perfect balance between
weight durability and corrosion
resistance Apple watch Ultra users will
also be greeted by new additions on the
body additions like the new
international orange action button that
can be customized to be used for
different functions a three microphone
array for optimal voice Clarity a larger
primary speaker and an emergency siren
speaker that emits an 86 decibel alert
which can be heard from up to 600 feet
away you'll also see a new depth gauge
and water temperature sensor which will
of course come in handy with extreme
water activities like scuba diving and
with that Apple has partnered with Huish
Outdoors to create the new oceanic Plus
app which turns the watch that you'll be
wearing every day into a fully capable
dive computer for recreational scuba
diving up to 40 meters some more
exciting developments implemented in
both the ultra and the series 8 include
health and safety there's a new
temperature sensor with a unique
two-sensor design one on the display and
one on the back Crystal so your watch
will measure both the temperature of
your body and your environment to reduce
inaccuracies when giving you your
reading these measurements are utilized
for their retrospective ovulation
estimates this means your watch can tell
you when you've likely ovulated as well
as show you your cycle deviations cycle
history cycle tracking and ovulation
estimates are just some of the use cases
that these sensors can be applied to
joining familiar features like blood
oxygen ECG and heart rate readings when
it comes to safety the Apple watch Ultra
and series 8 both include a new feature
crash detection using a high GeForce
accelerometer and improved three-axis
gyroscope your watch can now send alerts
to the proper authorities when it
detects a vehicle collision and don't
worry your watch won't accidentally call
9-1-1 if you throw your Apple watch
across the room or you accidentally drop
it it pairs yourself with your iPhone to
gather GPS data so it can tell if you're
going from car like speeds to a sudden
stop here's the new Apple watch box it
is a different type of box because most
of the other boxes or at least the outer
kind of cover is more smooth this has
more of a little texture to it this is
the titanium case with the orange Alpine
Loop oh whoa look at this it's adventure
package
we have a little Adventure booklet
wow oh wow this gets like on all new
like little directions to show you the
new features look at this little booklet
it's got some instructions on how to use
the new watch we've got the watch faces
like look at this box look at this the
mountains are waiting for us
this is great this is so nice and here's
the Apple watch Ultra and our watch band
these are a much thicker box like
usually it's like long thin but this is
like a little a little rectangle
the other one's just a long rectangle
a big watch face like in comparison to
the Apple watch SC that I just unboxed
this is like a monster
still so shocking like how large this is
and yet the weight of it is so much
lighter than I ever expected okay what
do we have in here I like that they put
the GPS coordinates cute oh no way it's
a braided Apple watch
cable I love this
wow this is the best surprise ever look
how nice
I did not expect that that was a very
sweet little treat so there's our Apple
watch Ultra now we need to unbox some
watch bands sorry I have one unboxed
here this is the Alpine Loop this is in
The Starlights we also have the yellow
Ocean band and the orange Alpine Loop
this is the yellow Ocean band okay I'm
gonna open The Ocean band first this one
didn't really fit my wrist very well it
was a little bit big when I did the
apple briefing but it looks so pretty I
love this new design for the Apple watch
bands they've got like a little tray
both sides here
thank you
this is a very substantial material
okay now we have the orange Alpine Loop
this is a fan favorite it was so light I
didn't think there was anything in there
and then this looked like there was
nothing in there and I was like wait a
minute what happened did I just get
trolled nope it's in there it's just so
light I think I'm gonna put the orange
one on question is which Apple watch am
I going to take off to put this one on
oh here it is it's happening it's
happening it's happening okay I gotta
try it on this is I haven't even tried
it on yet look at that my wrist is
really tiny it's really big like it is
but I feel like there's a lot of big
watch faces it's been a very long time
since I've worn a traditional watch so I
don't even know what that's like of
course setup is always pretty easy just
connect it to your iPhone we're gonna
set this up for myself hold that there
and that's it setup is going well and
now we're greeted with a new screen that
I've never seen before and that's
because we've never had an action button
on the Apple watch so the action bot is
saying choose what you'd like the action
button to do work out stopwatch Waypoint
backtrack dive flashlight on or off now
these are all various different options
that you can change so for me I'm going
to just pick oh my God I don't even know
this is too much pressure I'm gonna set
it up later in settings so this is the
depth app the depth app could
automatically open underwater and
measure temperature time and depth yes
open depth when submerged diving safety
underwater activities are risky starting
to reduce the risk of serious or fatal
injury when scuba diving always use a
backup device and follow diving safety
protocols and now it's sinking I guess
this means it's time to go outside
[Music]
[Applause]
throughout here onto Venice Beach this
is the first time I've taken the Apple
watch Ultra out into the wild we're
going to do a little bit of exploring
here in Venice and the first thing that
I want to test out is the new Compass
because on the new compass app you have
waypoints and backtracking now with
waypoints you can use this to set
specific waypoints all around the world
wherever you go if you like something if
you like a store or if you want to
remember a spot you can set a waypoint
for it and when you're in the area the
waypoints for that geolocation will pop
up on your Apple watch for me I'm going
to set a waypoint of where I parked my
car just in case I lose it which I
happen to do often another new feature
is backtracking now I love this for
hiking because my sister and I often get
lost when we go out on new trails and
this is going to be amazing because
we're basically going to be able to
leave breadcrumbs it also kind of
reminds me a little bit of when I'm
playing Far Cry and I'm out exploring
and I'm searching for different items I
have that little Waypoint in the little
line and I'm kind of just going to try
to find the items I've been trying to
get to this for freaking Waypoint I
guess I'll go around the mountain I have
to get there find the enemies find the
treasure find the gold whatever it is
that I'm looking for in my video game
but now it's real life and it's here on
my wrist
[Music]
so our exploration has taken us to the
end of Venice Pier and I have just
marked a waypoint so anytime I'm near
here that Waypoint will pop up I'm also
still backtracking my steps on this
adventurous outing that we're having but
I came here specifically because I'm
gonna jump off the pier to test out the
depth sensing and the new water
temperature I would like to but I
actually am not a very proficient
swimmer so I'm terrified that you may
never see me again if I jump into this
water and also I think jumping off the
pier is probably frowned upon so this is
the test that I've been waiting for this
is the underwater test now with the new
Apple watch it will have an app that
comes out later on it's called the
oceanic Plus app and that will basically
turn this into a dive computer but right
now I have it set so that as soon as it
is submerged into water it will activate
the depth sensing and it'll be able to
tell you the temperature of the water so
I'm going to try that out right now I'm
also not a good swimmer I don't like
going underwater so I'm doing this for
you guys I just bought this brand new
snorkel snorkel mask I don't think I
might have left the snorkel at home do I
look good nice we're going in I hope
this works not really sure what to
expect oh this is so warm this is like a
bath water
[Music]
oh
my goodness okay it says I'm one foot
under
this pool is only three feet
max depth three feet underwater times
four seconds this water temperature is
86 degrees
[Music]
foreign
for one second and I maxed up to three
feet water temperature was 86 degrees
now press any button to dismiss okay now
I gotta press and hold the crown to turn
off water lock
there you go
unlocked ejecting water
I just want to let you know oh Jenna's
filming in cinematic mode oh so now that
I faced my fear of swimming does this
mean that we think that I might be able
to try diving
those are two very different things
right very different I think I could do
it would you do it with me
[Music]
the Apple watch is made for fitness and
training and this by far more than any
other Apple watch is made for extreme
sports one of the cool things that I
like now about watch OS 9 is it does
have support for triathlons so you can
go from swim to bike to cycle and it'll
automatically detect each activity you
can set the action button to manually
switch between these but I think it's
really cool that this has the knowledge
and the ability to switch between each
activity without having to do a single
thing now since I'm not doing any
extreme activity I'm literally walking
around Venice Beach I'm going to start a
workout and I'm going to do an outdoor
walk I know it's pretty extreme so hold
on to your hats or something it's going
to get really wild up in here
let's start a walk
I just got a notification that says I'm
in a loud environment when these men
that I walk past yelled some vulgarities
[Music]
so it has a new speaker so I'm going to
call my sister hello hello how are you
I'm good how are you can you hear me
okay yeah I can hear you so it sounds
normal okay well that's good I can hear
you I'm on my new iPhone 14 pro Max
you're on your new iPhone 14 pro Max oh
my gosh what color did you get deep
purple I forgot to tell you that I'm on
the new Apple watch Ultra just giving
you a little call okay I'm gonna go okay
see you later bye bye it's hard to tell
if it was louder than the previous gen
since I am kind of outside and I do take
a lot of calls on my watch but I
definitely was able to hear her pretty
clear and she sounded more like a fuller
kind of sound so let's carry on to our
adventure
is that another Waypoint for cow oh I'm
setting so many great waypoints let's
carry on
the scenario is where GPS is kind of
hard to find or hard to reach where
there's buildings or you're in an area
where there's a lot of tree coverage
this now has L5 L1 GPS and a new antenna
design so you'll be able to get more
precise GPS location and accuracy and
also there's been some sketchy stuff
happening in Venice and I'm a little
scared so I'm going to test out the
siren on my Apple watch and just just to
see it just to make sure it works so if
I need some help there it is there it
goes it just progressively gets louder
[Applause]
it would be really ironic if the Apple
watch opened up their decibel meter and
said that you're in a loud scenario and
you're gonna have hearing loss because
the decibel range of this is 86 decibels
it could be heard up to 600 feet away so
somebody call 9-1-1 shorty something
something on the Dance Floor whoa I'm
gonna find us a location we're gonna go
to the Venice Pier sign and there it is
the venison shoddy fire burning on the
dance floor whoa speaking of fire
burning on the dance floor the
brightness of the screen goes up to 2000
nits and it's starting to get a little
bit darker now as the sun goes down but
a little bit ago when we were out
filming in the bright direct sunlight it
was really wild how well I could see the
display this is going to be incredible
for hikes and if you're out in
situations where it's super bright I am
so impressed with the display already
and another thing that I like about the
display is the fact that it's a flat
display instead of kind of like the
curved and rounded on the previous
version of the Apple watches it has such
a nice feel like it feels like a flat
table the touchscreen
oh I found a penny
I'm gonna add a waypoint so with this
larger watch face you are going to be
getting a better battery life so you can
get up to 60 hours in the low power mode
setting and you'll get about 36 hours of
normal usage you'll also get about 18
hours if you have LTE turned on and
you're using it all day long so I took
this directly out of the box and out
here to try it so I haven't even charged
it and the battery is at about 65 right
now so tomorrow I will be doing my first
full charge and I'll really be able to
test the battery out
[Music]
foreign
is they change depending upon where you
are so not all the waypoints that I set
earlier are going to be showing up
because the only the ones that I've set
in this General location are going to
appear so I'm going to set another one
up here for the skate park
[Music]
um I just got a free t-shirt I'm coming
to Venice Beach way more often free
t-shirt let's go get a hat
[Music]
we made it to the sign I now have a hat
I got a new t-shirt I am full on Venice
Taurus now we gotta go to the venison I
gotta add a waypoint and then we gotta
backtrack our way all the way back to
the car good thing I know exactly where
I'm going thanks to the Apple watch
Ultra okay let's go
[Music]
foreign
back I'm going to backtrack so I'm going
to go to my watch I'm going to hit this
pause button right here and I'm going to
retrace my steps so let's do it so you
can see that little Waypoint right there
it's showing me which way I should be
walking so if I'm going the wrong way
it's going to keep telling me which way
to go let's follow that little arrow
[Music]
retracing let's go
you see that little animation has
changed
[Music]
foreign
so it's telling me that at some point I
need to turn left so up here I'll turn
left and that should take us right back
on the route
[Music]
we're nearing our car destination and
now just looking at my watch it's
telling me where to go it's telling me
gotta keep going this way but I can see
the lines here on the little navigation
it's showing all of the steps that I
took we went down to the pier we went
this way we went that way we've gone all
sorts of ways we're almost there I can
see the destination it's in sight we
have traveled near we've traveled far I
can't believe the adventure that we've
had today I got a free shirt I did buy
the hat and I was able to backtrack my
way to my car all while adventuring in
Venice Beach so you can see the dots
right there the Waypoint has led me back
to my vehicle now our main Adventure was
to go see the Venice lights now while
the Venice lights did not turn on on the
sign that may have failed me but the
Apple watch did not so we're almost back
to the car can't believe it what an
adventure we've had little car
I have found my way back to you
arrive to the sign now whether we drive
there we walk the mission must be
[Music]
is it on oh it's blue isn't it usually a
different color we made it back the sign
and the lights are on
[Music]
this is kind of just my first
impressions of the Apple watch Ultra
since I'm not really able to do all of
the adventurous things that this watch
is really meant to do marathons
triathlons climbing really big mountains
and trekking to the depths of the ocean
I guess you wouldn't track to the depths
of the ocean you'd probably swim or I
don't know I don't I don't know anyway
My overall First Impressions though is
it's actually very light in comparison
to the Milanese loop with a stainless
steel it feels almost the same weight
it's kind of wild I also really like
this band my favorite band bill was the
one that I tried at the Apple event
which is the Trail Loop it's super thin
and it also has Velcro so it's very easy
to take on and off but these ones are
definitely made for more adventure
activities and the ocean ban is very
durable so that is something that you
could depend on it's staying on your
wrist while you're in the Deep depths of
the ocean I will be doing a follow-up
video after I've had some more time with
this but so far I'm really enjoying it
and I cannot wait to see how good the
battery life is you guys want to check
out some more of my videos that I have
here feel free to click on any of these
on the end screen it's apple season I
have a ton of content for you to check
out if you guys haven't already please
subscribe so you'll see my next video
and hit the Bell so you'll be notified
when it goes live leave me some comments
below and let me know what you think of
the Apple watch Ultra did you order one
did you not let me know I'll see you in
the next video bye
sure it's really nice I like it a lot
actually nice hat too I also like my hat
I have a new look this is what I call
tourist chic
[Music]